-Now I thought
I´d share some of my favorite
#ThatWasTMI stories
from you guys.
This first one´s
from @jeremyart.
-Hey-oh!
[ Applause ]
Last call.
-This one´s from @emilyscoby.
-Ohh.
[ Laughter ]
Ugh!
-This one´s from @MexicanSamoan.
He says --
[ Laughter ]
Right there is TMI almost.
Right there.
That´s TMI, yeah.
Tell me everything about him.
[ Laughter ]
-Don´t want to
piss that guy off.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This one´s from @camdfish.
[ Laughter ]
Why even get her a cake?
-Why get her a cake, then?
-I don´t know, man.
-Give her a sock on the nose.
-This is from, uh --
Kuh-jade? Kuh-ji--
Kay-ya-day?
-Key-hade?
-K-E-J-A-D-E.
-Could be Key-yah-day?
Kuh-jade?
Kej-dee?
-Shazh.
It´s pronounced "Shazh."
[ Laughter ]
Thanks a lot.
[ Applause ]
-You never know.
This one´s from @CXO-Insights.
-Ohh!
Ew!
-Uh, can I change seats, please?
This last one here
is from @-jeffreyhudson.
-Ohh!
-There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to TonightShow.com/hashtags.